dr karl weiss est avec nous bonsoir
docteur soir ça va bien il ya des gens
qui ont lu et qui m'ont écrit en fin de
semaine qui ont lu votre portrait dans
la presse une journée typique dans la
vie du dr weiss prison dit il me
reprocher je me suis roi pendant plus
vous l'accaparé à tous les jours et
c'est comment il peut avoir du temps
pour vous alors on apprécie ce que vous
faite docteur j'apprécie mais il faut
aussi fier c'est tous les gens qui
travaillent à l'hôpital pour ça il faut
le souligner c'est vraiment tout le
monde c'est un travail d'équipé c'est
les gens de l'entretien ménager les
infirmières les préposés les médecins
les résidents en médecine c'est vraiment
tout le monde l'ex travail et on voit
des choses assez extraordinaire même les
collègues des spécialités chirurgicales
je les embête un petit peu à la blague
qui viennent nous aider pour spécialité
médicale
alors c'est vraiment c'est important de
souligner que c'est vraiment tout le
monde on va voir les chiffres ensemble
quand on dit que le réseau hospitalier
n'est pas du tout débordés ce qui est
vrai dans l'ensemble du québec qu'on va
voir les données ce qui veut pas dire
comme bon c'est 6,5 pour cent le taux
d'hospitalisation aujourd'hui ou soins
intensifs 1,7 avec 226 ce qui ne veut
pas dire que dans les hôpitaux désignés
comme le vôtre vous soyez pas débordé
quand même un pas du tout on travaille
énormément vous avez l'hôpital a été
littéralement transformé pas le mien
juste le mien tous les hôpitaux du
québec qui ont été désignés vous
parlerez à n'importe lequel de mes
collègues et vous allez voir que c'est
un monde surréaliste dont on n'avait
jamais imaginé l'existence puisque on
voit quasiment rien d'autre que ce que
deco vite des cas de co vite 19 à toute
fin pratique on voit je vous dirai
peut-être 15% de se renvoyer avant pour
ce que tout ce qui est le reste dont cet
instinct monde où on a des unités
complètes maintenant de cobly d'où on ne
traite que des patients avec ça en a je
n'ai jamais vu des soins intensifs aussi
occupé ou que ce que tu vois
actuellement
et puis je suis passé par le h1n1 et
c'était vraiment pas comparable du tout
bon c'est ça alors que quand on dit que
les hôpitaux tiennent bien
pas comprendre par là que c'est depuis
que c'est une marche dans le parc au
monde il vous vous avez quoi il ya une
préparation
je pense que regardent moins de tags
globalement le réseau hospitalier de
soins aigus tient bien le coup mais
c'est un énorme travail s'est il va
falloir aussi un moment donné commencer
à ça c'est important de souligner a
commencé à traiter d'autres patients
pour d'autres choses parce que là on a
un ami à aulas sur à peu près tout et
n'importe quoi et un moment donné on
pourra pas continuer comme ça
éternellement non plus oui la présidente
des médecins spécialistes disaient ce
matin effectivement il faut recommencer
les autres opérations parce que sinon on
va on va avoir un retard incroyable tout
à fait là c'est clair bon très bien une
petite quand même comment vous voyez
l'absence de préparation dans certains
centres pour personnes âgées cherchez
pas vous ne vous êtes dans un hôpital
mais comment vous voyez comme nous on
nouvelle et c'est triste à mort on
aurait pu mieux se préparer quand même
dans certains lieux physiques
écoutez d'abord c'est d'une tristesse
absolue c'est je pense qu'il va falloir
penser différemment de comment traiter
nos aînés au québec
il va falloir même peut être repenser le
concept du ch slts qu'on doit à tout
prix mettre nos aînés dans ce genre de
situation là alors que peut-être qu'on
devrait favoriser un d'autres méthodes
peut être l'autonomie à la maison que le
plus possible et cetera
mais vous savez les ch celle des ont
toujours été un petit peu le parent
pauvre du système
c'était l'endroit où les gens ont
finalement allé pour des soins
chroniques pas très actif et est donc
quand je vous dis registre dans ma
spécialité c'est relativement récent
on avait commencé à pousser d'avoir des
infirmières en prévention des infections
dans les ch et celle des ça avait
commencé avec la crise du clostridium
difficile mais il ya encore beaucoup
d'efforts à faire alors les ch et celle
des c'est clair que c'est un
environnement où il va falloir repenser
par toute la structure en question
et puis investir beaucoup plus pour
qu'on donne à nos aînés et une qualité
de vie qui soit le plus approprié
possible tout à fait
dr vince une question pour vous en date
du 10 avril l'allemagne et la france ont
sensiblement le même nombre de personnes
infectées par contre la france à cinq
fois plus de mortalité que l'allemagne
comment peut-on expliquer cette énorme
différence devant une question de
beaucoup plus que les français donc
probablement que les gens en allemagne
qui ont été testés il ya beaucoup de
jeunes relativement bonne santé
il ya eu aussi je vous dirais
probablement d'autres facteurs
d'organisation qui ont fait que en
france ya eu beaucoup plus de décès il
faut aussi comprendre j'ai regardé la
carte française des tcl n'est pas
uniforme du tout la région de france qui
sont atteints c'est surtout l'est du
pays et la région parisienne et même à
l'intérieur de la région parisienne
vous allez voir que des différences
marquées entre les quartiers je dirais
les quartiers riches de paris et les
hâtivement arrive de paris entre les
banlieues qui sont riches et des
banlieues qui sont moins riches
donc même à l'intérieur de la france
c'est pas du tout homogène ya des villes
tout l'ouest du pays donc les grandes
villes de l'ouest que ce soit nantes
bordeaux toulouse
même lyon sont des villes qui sont
beaucoup moins touchés que paris ou que
l'est du pays donc il ya des différences
importantes qui sont probablement a
expliqué par d'autres facteurs que
simplement la qualité des soins qui
aurait pu leur être attribuées je
souligne quand même en passant que le
canada se situe pas si mal là quand on
se compare on est à fait le va bien oui
oui le canada fait relativement bien
dans l'histoire on a été entre
guillemets chanceux d'être savez ça
s'est déplacée vers l'ouest mais quand
on se compare à nos collègues et nos
amis américains
on voit qu'on est beaucoup mieux au
canada mais là encore aux états unis il
ya des différences marquées entre les
états entre certains endroits regarder
l'état de new york
regardez la californie on dirait que ces
deux pays différents quant à la coved 19
oui puisqu'il faut 60 à 70% de la
population pour un portier qui a eu la
corvée 19 avant d'atteindre l'immunité
de masse en se confinant et s'ils ne
faisons nous pas que retarder notre
propre contamination est donc l'immunité
alors oui non oui parce que il est à
nancy le virus était bénin est pas
problématique on dirait écouter tout le
monde va l'attraper
on sait qu'à peu près lorsque 60 % de la
population à la trappe et la
transmission va diminuer et on aurait
dit on va faire ça le problème c'est que
vous voyez que ceux des russes créé
énormément de problèmes au niveau des
personnes âgées au niveau de l'impact au
niveau de l'utilisation des soins dans
les soins aigus
donc il faut en atténuer son impact de
plus possible et c'est un peu ça qui est
en arrière de cette stratégie
éventuellement un certain nombre
d'individus vont être affectés la vraie
stratégie on peut la résumer de la façon
suivante on essaie de jouer le temps le
plus possible de gagner le plus de temps
possible jusqu'à l'arrivée potentielle
d'un vaccin et à ce moment là on va en
réduire l'impact sur l'ensemble de la
population pour épargner des vies
exactement pour épargner des vies
vous êtes quand même pas rien évidemment
bourbeux numéro cinq s'est beaucoup
revenu en fin de semaine à la lumière
des deuxième vague qui semblent survenir
en asie par exemple est on réellement
immunisés où peut-on l'attraper deuxième
fois la coved 19
alors c'est vraiment pas clair dans le
sens que ce qui sort d'asie se sont pas
des études très très bien fait pour
l'instant on a encore beaucoup de
questionnements là dessus pour l'instant
ce qui semble être ressortir de façon
globale une fois qu'on l'a attrapée
qu'on a guéri on est immunisé
certainement pour quelques années à
moins que le virus se mettent à changer
de façon drastique
en termes de si vous voulez mutation ce
qui n'est pas du tout typique pour ce
virus là donc une idée actuelle vous
êtes vous avez guéret vous est immunisée
donc voilà même s'il ya des sages
examinaient mais vous avez raison le
souligner parce qu'il faut quand même
pas devenir fou là il ya une fin à la
spirale je m'excuse mais souvent séduit
faut le dire aux gens c'est dû à des
erreurs par les tests ce genre d'étude
là c'est des gens qui ont été testés
positifs négatifs est encore positif
donc souvent ce sont des erreurs dans
les tests très bien j'ai une petite
dernière
rapidement quelqu'un qui était en bonne
santé dans la numéro 7 dans la
quarantaine actif mais qui est sujet à
faire des plumes au niveau des
bronchites j'ajouterai de l'asthme est
ce que ces gens là doivent s'inquiéter
non la réalité c'est que vous n'avez pas
plus à risque que la population générale
parce qu'en réalité c'est que vous êtes
probablement pas de première répétition
si vous êtes en bonne santé et dans la
quarantaine vous faites simplement de
simples affections virales l'asthme
c'est sûr ça peut être un facteur de
risque mineur mais ça sent pas être le
plus celui qui se démarque le plus
actuellement
dr weiss merci encore une fois de nous
avoir parlé c'est très apprécié le
nombre de courriels vous en reviendrez
riez pas du nombre de courriels qui
rendre pour des questions qui vous sont
dessinés merci bonne fin de journée
au revoir bonne soirée